cbs news legal analyst ricky clement is
here ricky good morning the president
and his lawyers say this is political
and without merit but we're talking more
than 200 pages a lot of detail it seems
serious is it it is very serious and
it's serious for two reasons
number one is she has given referrals to
the southern district of new york u.s
attorney's office she has given a
referral to the irs
and all of this material is out there
for other prosecutors to grab onto the
second reason is
she is looking at what she can do to
stop donald trump his family and two
other people who work with him
to she's stopping them from working it's
like the death knell of the trump
organization because the bans that she
is looking to have enacted by a judge
are to stop them from doing business in
the state of 250 million in retro
retribution and a ban for five years on
operating in new york city as well as a
life ban
for any of them from serving as a
director or an officer and putting an
independent monitor that's like a
receivership or a consent decree this is
serious indeed plus i think the most
interesting part of why it's serious is
it's a dare to alvin bragg who is the
d.a in new york county in manhattan
because it's daring him because they've
worked together they've cooperated and
it's saying i'm giving you 222
pages i'm giving you a road map a
template of all the criminal action that
my office believes that the trump
organization and the trumps have done so
i dare you not to prosecute now ricky i
want to turn to the classified documents
found at mar-a-lago now there has not
been any criminal case as of yet but
president trump has repeated a possible
defense let's take a look
if you're the president of the united
states you can declassify just by saying
it's declassified even by thinking about
it because you're sending it to
mar-a-lago or to wherever you're sending
it
ricky so what do you make well i didn't
know that you could declassify documents
um by either waving a magic wand or now
by
telepathy by thinking about it well i
think that's a process
now of course there is a process and yes
a president may declassify documents but
one of the things that might have
happened with the special master was to
look at the challenge of classification
which now they don't have to he doesn't
have to do and say document by document
when did you declassify it what process
did you use who witnessed it right so
there's a process yes there is yeah well
ricky we thank you for joining us it's
always good to be with you good to have
you all right